Molly mixing no oh all right lovable
what shall we do this yes let's do this
let's yes let's do this let's do this
let's not explain the game at all well
this is nice quad nice cool it's it's
pretty self-explanatory pretty much
people will get I mean they watch it and
your honor squad yeah I'm ready
I hope you all observed that the map is
not left and right it's top and bottom
this time well this time I don't think
they saw the last one no but you know
you guys okay thank you are we gonna be
blue or red we're gonna be on the same
team whatever it is for the first one
then the next one let's just do that up
is blue why is this so complicated
oh wait what alright
that team what are we wrong I don't know
I don't know what you did wrong
up up wasn't a team option I said are we
gonna be red or blue and you said I'm up
well what was it one of the offices good
I called those I call it I call those I
call those I even all soared scheme
Evo's coming in I call swords oh my god
there [ __ ] like crazy
Oh God I got him okay good kill well
coming in the left side Adam go get you
kill these guys no I got the life side
with my I guess oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh mercy
yeah I got a horsie dude oh I'm getting
there the bond arrows so opiates nuts
you have it yeah the level two one cuz
it shoots exploding arrows cuz I'm gonna
get this damn flag I guess I'll get it
since I got the horse school you can
cheaply kill through the wall probably
oh my god I just got so rekt
Oh Bravo grassman Oh No god they're all
in our base lady feds for god sakes
sorry they're gonna win Dakota win
that's it if it wasn't clear I'm the
purple arrow over my house but no I'm
the Fertile arrow over my head our night
no I'm the / I'm the pink sorry pink
what I meant was painted limestone who's
orange is that Wade not obably blue
orange is computer on ya the computer is
oh man
Oh God hot repaired rocking us I'm here
flag [ __ ] no got it
nice save the flag you're welcome nice
look there does I got killed
Oh God okay I think the downfall of this
map is that it turns into an open air
really got him oh oh wow
Marcus Pro holding down the entire left
side by himself
thank you over me cover me cover me I
got your back see see what see zeros man
arrows my house come on you're so Opie
with those arrows right now I know I'm
magic just some [ __ ] I bet I've been
drilled come here you [ __ ] I'll get
these swords and all my flag I don't
need help
hahaha the Gallic Ozzy geese oh oh that
kamikaze rage is huge
I know it's unfair I returned the flag
my bows and arrows
alright how good I was worried the flag
I was all good come back here I'll get
my swords going again ok your arrows
back I know thank you
thank you mom guys help with the flag
the guys haha I've been murdered I gonna
score the [ __ ] flag I was murdered
Wow laser jeez did you just return oh
they got it I got it
ok alright yeah thanks to me I don't
know what that had yeah oh [ __ ]
the only thing I can do is like
defensive with the arrows I got a point
come with me minions someone do
something I'm in the flag they're sworn
by minions right now wait who's held me
I've got the flag go up to Mario I got
your back
well no maybe I don't now we're good
we're good watch your right side in our
face yeah good score boys there's also
more pose if you need a mark I don't
think it can go up any more it's it's
completely maxed up oh good guilt line
wait wait minions you'll get here I'm
gonna tried spore again I'm coming back
Oh someone's got the flag yeah wait
we're totally think we're probably of
wrecking these guys right now oh I say
it's I shy like an idiot army guard
mares I couldn't do it camel may tell
day
you and me mark the bow and arrow
brothers yeah will defend whoever
whatever fool decides to look how many
skeletons are just piled up in that one
spot yeah oh yeah what if I get killed
they arrowed you Jesus what Oh what all
things they switch down my weapons
oh the reset like eliminates all weapons
okay alright good flag return they're
pushing they're pushing left side so
they're not [ __ ] ah I so dead I so good
you so dead ain't only useful but I got
one
oh they're going we got our flight they
got our flight are we winning we better
be winning because it's ridiculous I
totally return that [ __ ] yeah mom's oh
no how I got bombs but oh whoa hey I
don't think they can come back at this
point uh even though they're totally
diamonds on the left side of the map
good return oh Jesus
alright or just take the powerup that's
fine
you know for as much as I think we're
okay I'm stuck I'm stuck I'm stuck it Oh
games over I guess I can't move well
it's like when Lincoln games I even over
but we stopped moving
I have worst game ever I think I had a
great game I had a pretty good 40 Oh Bob
still had more than me yeah baby I
dealing it all at 7021 all right less
death I died that knows Danny did I -
flags though so that's why I died so
much probably yeah the arrows were good
but it's just like I couldn't do much
besides kind of pepper um from a fight
oh you were totally holding down the
it'd be a completely exposed left side
though that's true yeah I was able to
keep that open alright so we just play
CTF you want to play a different game
mode sure gladiator is like last one
standing wins you get more points if
you're in the middle of the map king of
hill king in the hell yeah free-for-all
king of the elderly down let's do it oh
that map sucks
MF sucks I wasn't okay let's play the
first one this one's good it was dewy
yeah No
we're having fun playing games wait wait
you have to wait it's character waves
what well what's you doing wait well
then so if I somehow managed to get
arrows again are you all gonna suffer my
wrath a mark are you penguin I am pink
truce truce truce truce truce okay truce
truce truce mystery Oh suck it
oh no I treated gills with yellows got
the Kamikaze I did look at [ __ ] like
an [ __ ] what else am I gonna do where
I only get points if I'm alive Comic Con
shucks I don't know be sure oh oh you
guys try to kill sweet King oh hey I'm
King ha ha ha [ __ ] oh boy just laughs
it's up of a who would imagine deputies
you almost Engrish suck purpley razor II
thingy Oh marks getting arrows I am
getting arrows Oh God
oh [ __ ] I guess oh say hi oh boy for
Freud funk I just got my arrows hey
Martin how's it go no no come here buddy
oh no this is it oh no no it's okay it's
okay we could be friends
damn it suck my minions shall take over
al Camden well all right well okay we're
heating my god I got ski boots level two
I'm like I'm like a I'm like really fast
this is like slight delay on this [ __ ]
is not Wow oh my god oh god repents
magic laser thing Oh God took him out
for some cumin thanks you saved my life
oh no oh my god oh okay yeah yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] orange no it's got dandruff
how's the drilling I elating us know
okay that's probably not worth our time
huh why not oh Jesus
Oh God minions fathers don't get away
boy oh well he won't work where is a
home arrows are so useless in this game
I know I thought they were gonna be good
but it turns out ha yeah then I'm a
shield Oh taste my longsword in your
mouth whoa oh [ __ ] Oh God Ray's running
in a circle like that not helpful
oh no super crossbow Matt Matt neck
what Oh son of a [ __ ] oh come here mark
No
yeah my Hill okay okay okay all right
okay I'm totally distracted by mark and
let myself get slightly murder Oh
totally hit you first Bob you I'll thank
God I killed the guy who got the bombs
whoa no you ruined yellow guy has steel
oh so stupid like the power-ups don't
work oh he's kamikaze Hey look is that a
3G [ __ ] it looks like a crazy ho not
worth a bar key node oh well okay butter
white is is just cleaning house on this
[ __ ] like annihilating everyone oh my
god yeah white is white is absolutely
destroying right now I think it's just
cuz he's not going for anything I think
just dive-bombing into the center and
hoping ha ha teal [ __ ] wait oh come
on be my bud feet I just gotta jump back
up to the last bit of coins here oh man
joy is destroyed oh man one worse than
me yeah 39 kills - what a boss wait wait
how did he do so terribly I replay the
center are you Blue Knight Wayne yeah
what are you doing in the center on your
chip
oh man oh goodness alright you want to
play that again that was really fun oh
yeah yeah just a different miss map or
oh god that mattered is intense yeah
let's do this this is gonna be some [ __ ]
that'll be a oh man okay fine what's
yeah until this opens up it's gonna be
crazy to try and get over to the hill
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I had a guitar
sword
are there different characteristics
between the colors are they all
functionally the same they're all
functionally the same okay gotcha it's
just so you know which one of them
little lights as you I didn't say
functionally I said functionally or they
all [ __ ]
oh come on come on it's a bunch of bull
well Gundam wise yellow get all the
goddamn power-ups and everyone else is
left to suck chodes well I was in there
for a second I got yeah what the hell
we're gonna get so wrecked right now no
well that's a bunch of [ __ ] I'm not
able to do worry but you guys want to
see some [ __ ] that remember ha now I'm
gonna win [ __ ] are you yo you
are I opened up a wholesome up to my own
little area oh jesus there's so many
people coming right now
Oh God well yeah I totally opened up a
hole so that my side can get into this
to the hill immediately upon spawning oh
how RP be able to kill me so quickly
it's like it shouldn't be like that but
it should be the way it is but it do not
aah whoa aah oh [ __ ] whoa
such a mess yes yes I got Hill points
yes ah damn it Wade white got a triple
kill oh Jesus yeah Jesus who is that
mark doing right no no hay gives you
points ok why did you dig so much
because it gave points he gave a lot of
but why did I die I got ham and this is
such [ __ ] I got some lie are some
[ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] it's good
probably like Marcus flag it's like I
should be alive but no oh no kasi why no
laser gun
all oh no God oh that was awful
I had a shield and I became you I hate
the spawn location yeah this one's tough
to get out of them ha ha ha did this
spawn it's like he's you spot at the
wrong time you're [ __ ] now leave me
alone leave me alone boys many minions
many many minions opening go how did you
kill me you've gotta be kidding me
do you see that Bob you shouldn't look
like you're me dead she's totally right
oh thanks Wade you're welcome
I appreciate that you live die ha ha oh
damn it yeah i can't get any turn pills
those are my boots those are my boots
you suck you suck I want the boots aah
no [ __ ] only red guys about to get the
magic staff of douchiness i guilty [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh who is Oh
I'm actually not losing by that much oh
if you hey you break out of the ice
faster oh you're welcome everybody
welcome welcome to death you're welcome
well that's gonna really help you thank
you I know
Oh aha oh [ __ ] ok well come here Wade oh
oh Jesus oh god I'm so distracted by
mark I walked right into another guy
holy crap
Marcus - ok Marcus - Oh Bea wait Oh son
of a [ __ ]
yes Oh when you have a shield
are you kidding young I have a shield
god damn me [ __ ] you ladies and ruin my
fun
you're such a prick mark was like setup
in there too he was all over that shield
tune you just got rolling with the
kamikaze screw you no no watch this I
was having fun by myself up with a drill
and you come and kill me [ __ ] you no
laughing me you're you good you're a bad
person
yeah I don't even know what happened
what I was off trying to get see if the
drill had a second level and I did and I
was gonna drill some bushes but wait has
to end my fun mom cuz he's a dick he's
an [ __ ]
Oh God alright whatever what else we got
oh you play juggernaut or domination
how's juggernaut word can I kill wait up
the golden thing in the middle and you
become the juggernaut [ __ ] everyone
tries to kill you I like that yeah I'm
gonna kill Wade yeah let's let's do this
map
I think it's free for all so alright
prepare to die everybody bairdi wait
okay I wish we can make it everyone but
target with the whole game please let
our spawn me I hope or Brian next to
each other oh thank god guys one go yeah
way is that a machine gun or something
oh my god
god oh my gosh wait why'd you kill me
we're going after him
oh [ __ ] we really need to get boughs and
bonds and stuff huh oh my god yes yes
dammit
orange kill him orange help huh
ah I almost had him how I killed him but
he got me son of a [ __ ]
don't let weight have fun you guys
[ __ ] suck I just want to hold it once
oh oh
guys I hate you guys oh you think
juggernaut would be able to take more
than just one hit oh man oh my god
[ __ ] you yes yes this is me
ah don't get me mark don't get me no ah
mine come at me bro
er Matt oh trying yeah what the hell my
snowcone i am holy [ __ ] okay oh god no
yeah yeah uh-huh
Oh hold on let him don't let him oh yeah
okay ah you guys [ __ ] sock
y'all got Damon oh no that was mine oh
Jesus oh come on
how did none of you hit him oh Jesus
Christ
supposed to fit oh no oh no oh god he's
coming
oh he's coming oh yeah sure sure
oh geez yeah are you kidding me
know what's doing oh god he caught me in
his own explosion the [ __ ] Oh orange
you bastard
god damn it I can't even [ __ ] touch
it I just got it I like it
I was right there over it oh I don't
think I am for any of this game how did
my guy okay
fine mine god damn it uh couples lucky
white lucky white but not of ice cream
on my screen it was god damn it
and millions
ah yes no you idiot green you [ __ ] oh
Jesus Christ
that's what we ate mark to [ __ ] have
it some more fun I think I deserve it
don't you Oh eat a dick he how many
dicks just long let's healthy serving of
dick big one a big dick Oh mark go away
oh well okay that makes sense not damn
it [ __ ] shitty power-ups and boom I
win ah I got second yeah
[ __ ] ah I like that game mode that game
most fun stupid game was really fun
never like that
hey nobody gonna stop buoy Buzz Aldrin